it's now called the 10 million dollar
concrete street
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about a 10 million
dollar project
so what is the 10 million dollar street
you might be asking
well it is four side by side precast
concrete houses
for four separate clients each client
came to us at
different periods of time and it just so
happened that we were aligned to do
every single one the street itself is
absolutely beautiful now
but unfortunately being in a moon boot i
don't know if you guys can see that
still
and hopping around i don't have the
ability to go out on site
and get actual photos of these so today
we're going to be discussing
the most expensive one through 3d
animation before we dive in i want to
take a minute to note
that i've re-rendered the front of these
four houses today
to make sure to give you guys the
absolute best quality
the internals are still from the
original design and the colors have
changed a little bit
so the most expensive out of all four of
these designs is the second from the
left
it is a two story design which features
four bedrooms
three and a half bathrooms a glass
office kitchen
living dining and a scullery it also
plays host to an upstairs
sitting area for the kids a wine cellar
down below
an entertaining deck a pool and also a
lift
now the clients had a very specific
brief in mind for this project
and they laid out all the conditions
before we got started
first of all they wanted a light and
bright house they wanted to be
absolutely saturated with natural light
they wanted to be able to entertain
guests whenever the opportunity arose
they wanted to have their own private
quarters which meant they felt like they
were on holiday most of the time
but at the same time they also wanted a
space away from the kids
the clients wanted to be able to work
from home but also to be able to work
with the family if they needed to it's a
little bit ironic that this client came
in pre-covered
and unfortunately this house isn't
finished completely
so they haven't been able to enjoy their
home office
whilst covered was happening but they
will get to enjoy it very very soon
one unique feature they described and
they truly wanted was a kids cooking
bench
this would allow the kids to be able to
help out in the kitchen when the parents
needed some assistance
in addition they wanted to be able to
connect the indoors and the outdoors
seamlessly this meant an entertaining
area from indoor
outdoors from both the backyard and the
front yard
which meant including a winter balcony
into the design of course it is very
standard in australia that everybody
wants at least a two-car garage so this
was also added to the brief so how did i
design
this beautiful home and how did i
address every element of the client's
brief
well let's start by looking at natural
light and letting it be
saturated by light throughout the day as
soon as you walk into the home you're
greeted with a double story
light well for the living and dining
area this means that that space being
north facing
is continuously flooded with light it is
also incorporated with boxed out windows
and louvers which aren't modeled the
clients wanted to be able to entertain
but they had
limited space on the block the block was
only 12 meters by 40 meters long
which meant approximately 480 square
meters
of total land mass by incorporating a
bi-fold door that opened up the entire
living room dining room area
onto the entertaining deck and then
incorporating a wrap around pool around
the side of the premises
it truly gave the indoor outdoor
connection they were looking for
as well as a very unique entertaining
space to be able to tie it back in to
the holiday vibe and the holiday
ambience of this property
tropical trees were planted around the
pool and
the master suite was situated smack bang
in the middle
it was surrounded by the lap pool and it
could be accessed
directly from the main entertaining deck
or from inside the living room area
which is completely separated from the
three bedrooms upstairs
one with a private ensuite and one
additional bathroom as well
the sitting area for the kids which is
more than likely going to be used as a
gaming area
was also situated upstairs i made sure
to incorporate a glass wall here because
i wanted the parents to be able to keep
a close eye on the kids
whenever somebody was around this was a
very important feature to the family
to be able to interact with one another
no matter where they were in the home
so the big question that everybody's
asking is how much
does this beautiful home cost well the
client originally had a budget of
1.8 million australian dollars this also
included a hundred thousand dollar
budget
for furniture fittings and to fill the
wine cellar
which is a very generous budget at the
end of the day the current estimate for
this build is 1.6 million
australian dollars plus landscaping plus
a pool
so that brings us in to a grand total of
1.75
million australian dollars 50k under
budget
at the current time the client was
ecstatic that there was a little bit of
spare cash
left over in the budget because part of
their brief was to
incorporate a large space of free wall
where they could incorporate some of the
family art now they have a very large
private collection which they were
looking to add to so this gave them the
perfect opportunity
to add to their private art collection
now from one professional to another i
truly want to know your opinion
if you're an architecture student an
architect an engineer or just a person
looking to build their dream home i want
you to drop a comment down below let me
know your thoughts on this design
if you want to see the rest of this 10
million street
and what you would change keeping in
mind every single country every single
state has different planning policies
and regulations
so think of this as just a hypothetical
best case scenario for yourself as a
dream home
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that like button
down below help this video
grow with the algorithm and if you want
to see more of my content smash that
subscribe button too
and as always i'll see you next monday